from the daily wire says parents at
litchfield elementary school
in arizona are infuriated over the
district's proposed equity plan that's
infused with elements of critical race
theory
the idea that america is rooted in
racism the district's transformation
equity work plan uh centers around the
definition of anti-racism which claims
that being not racist is insufficient
the definition suggests that parents and
educators must be actively fighting
against racism in all its forms though
what is considered racist is often
subjective
um during a school board meeting parents
slammed the board members who crafted
and supported the equity plan
one parent threatened to hold a recall
campaign against board members so
we have some of the audio here and i
always appreciate that when there's
audio of parents or
students fighting back resisting
that's that's a good thing that's that's
encouraging so let's let's play this
let me just tell you my kids are a
minority group i am hispanic
never once have they come home and said
that they felt victimized
or discriminated against because of
their race or ethnicity
i've done a lot of research into this
transformational
equity work document as well as mr
kennedy's theory radical
theory unproven
without a lot of supporting facts and
i'm deeply concerned for my kids who are
in this district
i have had over a dozen teachers reach
out to me
frustrated and upset over what is being
thrown their
way with this transformational equity
work
thanking me for speaking up for them
because they can't do it themselves
for fear of retaliation and possible
discrimination
further on the document references
reducing disciplinary action by race
reviewing library books and hiring based
on race
ethnicity gender identity faith sexual
orientation
socioeconomic class and age
you know what we have fought and battled
for equal rights in this country
this doesn't sound like equal rights it
sounds like we're going to go higher
based on
meeting a quota well you have to excuse
some of the the dramatic music there
underneath that's that wasn't that
wasn't our addiction but
there is the uh yeah there's parents
parents speaking out against this
insanity which
which is great um it's this is at a
minimum is what's going to be needed
parents to be aware and involved and
speaking out if you
if you feel
that you have no choice but to send your
kid to public school then you
at a minimum you got to be doing this
you have to be on top of it you have to
be aware of everything that's happening
talking your kids about it every day
when they get home
right get get the full report of what
happened what they were taught
um go to the school board meetings
you pay attention you got to do this
you have to do it or you're going to
lose your child
i mean it's that that's that's where
we're at you're going to lose your child
maybe not physically but you're going to
lose them mentally
emotionally spiritually you're going to
lose them in any every other way
the school system is going to take your
child from you
and replace your kid with someone else
turn them into something all the values
all the ideas that you have
instill all the the priorities and
everything that that you have instilled
in your child
the school system's job that they've
given themselves
is to take all that away and replace it
um but i can't help but but think every
time i
watch a video like this i can't help but
think that it's
a little bit like trying to empty the
ocean with a thimble
there's it's it's
there's too much the school system now
school systems across the country are so
fundamentally beholden to
you know left-wing doctrines that
there's not a lot that can be done
to change
[Music]
except for as i always say get your kids
out of public school system
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated